I'm Chris geres professor ameritus of
mechanical engineering at Stanford
University let's answer some questions
from the internet this is Automotive
[Music]
support at donkey Del asks should I buy
an Eevee now or wait a couple years
whilst they are still improving
technology and prices come down one
thing you may want to think about is
Ford has recently announced that they're
going to use Tesla's charging system on
their future electric vehicles Tesla
built the supercharger Network
specifically for their own car but other
manufacturers have decided that that's
actually a really good engineering
option and so they are Engineering in
the Tesla chargering system into their
cars so if what's out there today meets
your needs go ahead and buy but if not
you probably don't have long to wait
until something comes out that does at
punis wonders I wonder why solar powered
cars aren't a thing yet so if I take the
Mercedes behind me that's a really large
car I could fit maybe four solar panels
each of those under Peak conditions
would produce about 400 WT put it
together and I have 1,600 Watts almost
enough to power this hair dryer
somewhere on the order of about 2
horsepower all right but maybe I could
use this as an alternative to charging
that same amount of power would actually
be less effective than plugging your
electric car into a standard 120 volt
wall outlet it would really take forever
to charge so if you want a solar powered
car simply put solar panels on your roof
generate electricity and use it to
charge your electric car at Allan
bucksley asks why isn't there a huge
Market to retrofit most popular petrol
cars with battery packs and electric
motors so you can take a petrol car and
turn it into an electric vehicle my team
and I did that with this DeLorean in
order to fit everything in we actually
had to design and fabricate our own
subframe for the car to hold these new
components but this is not the easiest
way to go about getting an electric car
you're going to spend a lot more time
and money than you would would simply
buying an electric vehicle the challenge
is is that your car was designed to have
an engine and a gas tank if you start to
pull in electric vehicle components
there's a lot of things you have to ask
like how safe is that going to be in a
crash what have you done to the weight
distribution of the car so this is why
you don't really see many electric
vehicle retrofits out there at the
alterior kid writes how do self-driving
cars see self-driving cars can use a
range of different sensors Radars can be
very helpful in metallic objects that
are near the car but sometimes it's hard
to tell exactly what that radar is
bouncing off of cameras give a picture
of the world that's not unlike what we
see with our eyes but it doesn't really
give you distance information finally
lidar or laser scanners this is a series
of beams of light that tells very
precisely how far away an object is from
the lar you'll see that the lar is
spinning on top of our X1 vehicle behind
me right now and it's painting a picture
of me sitting here at this table so if I
move my arms you can see the image move
each one of these lines represents one
of the spinning lasers the color tells
how intense of a reflection the laser is
getting so autonomous cars see by using
a variety of sensors and AI to turn all
of these sensor signals into a picture
of the environment at kindman 726 726 57
asks why do autonomous vehicles have
steering wheels our Federal Motor
Vehicle Safety standards are generally
interpreted to mean that all cars have
to have driver controls it's easier for
manufacturers to Simply leave the
steering wheels and Driver controls in
the cars Engineers like to talk about
levels of automation a level one vehicle
is a system with an adaptive cruise
control something that uses a radar to
follow another vehicle safely or a lane
keeping system a level two combines
these two systems but the driver needs
to remain with their hands on the wheel
a level three autonomous vehicle that's
this Mercedes eqs here that car will
actually drive itself in limited
conditions in traffic jams the driver
can take their hands off the wheel and
their eyes off the road a level four
automated vehicle is a vehicle that can
drive itself within a specified area
these driverless Robo taxis that you see
companies like Cru level five
autonomous vehicle is really the highest
level that's a car that can drive from
one point to any other point that you
want that car obviously ly won't need a
steering wheel but that's a long ways
off in the future at cerat wonders how
will flying cars operate there are
several manufacturers out there looking
at very light aircraft that could take
off and land vertically and might travel
electrically over 50 to 60 miles looking
a lot like bigger versions of the drones
you may be flying these aircraft could
in fact operate autonomously in some
ways that's an easier problem than
trying to make a robo taxi you don't
have to to worry about pedestrians or
many other vehicles if you're flying
fairly low over the ground at Hazel asks
can anyone explain to me why Miatas are
cool now it's a Miata they have a 50/50
weight distribution when you turn your
steering wheel what you're trying to
control is the yaw rate of the car or
how fast it's turning in many cars what
you'll see is a yaw rate response that
tends to oscillate the car kind of
Wiggles as it's getting into its turning
rate but with a 50/50 weight balance
like the Miata has the car has a neutral
steering characteristic when you turn
your steering wheel you get a nice
smooth response so if you want to learn
to race you're going to find that this
neutral steering characteristic and the
Miata is the perfect way to learn racing
at y1 8698 writes drove down I40 earlier
and hit a long and indistinguishable
object falling from the car in front of
me my car drifted at high speed for
about 5 Seconds wonder how autonomous
vehicles will react to this autonomous
vehicles need to react to unexpected
situations on the road with skills that
are as good as the very best human
drivers that was the reasoning behind
building our autonomous drifting
DeLorean Marty Marty is able to drift
intentionally putting the car sideways
so that it's very very controllable and
it can track exactly the path that it
wants even in emergency situations at
teso Fan 420 writes you built a drift
machine out of a DeLorean yes so in the
hands of an inexperienced driver you're
likely to over rotate and spin out but a
skilled Drifter can keep the car
sideways and maneuver the car with
pinpoint accuracy this is what we were
trying to do with our software we've now
largely achieved the ability to control
the vehicle's path within a few
centimeters while sideways at wean zero
asks why were cars back then more boxy
and more curvy now older cars were
certainly more boxy they came from car
gages in the early days would often be
built upon a frame and somebody else
would build a body that went on top of
it at that time there wasn't a lot of
attention paid to aerodynamics or how
lightweight a car body could be in fact
if you went a little bit further there
still wasn't a lot of attention paid to
aerodynamics but more towards Tail Fins
and what the car looked like the size of
the tail fins became an important
marketing feature with new cars so in
the 1970s there was a severe energy
crisis and that made manufacturers want
to develop cars that were lighter weight
and more fuel efficient the way to make
them lighter weight was to use unibody
construction design the car really as
one unit the way to save fuel was to
make cars more aerodynamic and that
really changed the shape to the sleeker
shapes that we associate with modern
cars in the future one area that
manufacturers are really looking at is
removing the side mirrors which create a
fair amount of drag and replacing these
with cameras at kuc George asks why are
vehicles from the 7 s outlasting
vehicles from 2022 cars in the 1970s had
very few computers with a reasonable set
of tools you could maintain that car
then and continue to maintain that car
today the price that we pay for cars
that are more fuel efficient and more
environmentally friendly is that they've
become more computerized cars
increasingly have over-the-air software
updates will you be able to continually
update your software in the future it's
become impossible to do all of the work
yourself on a modern vehicle at
planetary JY asks why you put spoilers
on race cars to make sure that they can
grip the ground better so if you think
about an airplane they generate so much
lift that they can overcome the force of
gravity and fly through the air we can
put something like an upside down
airplane wing on the car which is a
spoiler you can generate so much
downforce with aerodynamics that you can
overcome gravity imagine that I create a
Formula 1 track upside down if I get my
car to run that way my down Force
becomes up force it could actually stay
stuck to this upside down trap some
people just attach something to the back
of their Honda Civic to look cool that's
not an engineering thing more of a
styling choice at Lumen rio1 asks so
you're telling me that if someone puts
up a sign with the image of a green
Traffic Light it will confuse autonomous
cars maybe if it's using cameras to try
to make sense of its current environment
it may very well be looking for traffic
signals if it finds one on the back of a
semi and not actually signaling an
intersection it could get confused by
that one of the difficult things about
programming autonomous cars is you have
to think in advance about things that
might confuse them news reports from San
Francisco show that people have been
able to confuse whmo cars by putting a
cone on the hood of the car that's
something I doubt any engineer would
have thought about when they were
designing the automated vehicle at
litter picker Pro wonders will cars of
the future have wooden Wheels can't get
much greener than that are we going that
direction in the future no but on the on
the other hand you may have tires that
are coming from Shrubbery Bridgestone
has been working with guul which is a
shrub that produces hypoallergenic latex
tires could be biodegradable we've paid
a lot of attention to pollution from the
tailpipe of cars as tires wear out they
produce little bits of rubber and
petroleum products that can actually
cause health issues at Mr Xavier M
writes get at me Ferrari versus Porsche
but both of these marks have tremendous
racing history on the Ferrari side
you've got that Italian styling but I'm
going to have to actually come down on
the side of the German Precision if you
want handling designed precisely to go
where you're commanding with your
steering and your throttle it's hard to
beat a portion at real gritty boy zero
asks why does people get in Crash when
they have on Tesla autopilot so
psychologists know that if we don't have
enough to do our mind wanders and is
hard to keep our attention on being
ready to take control if we need to
Tesla's autopilot are level two
automation systems they require the
human driver to be engaged and in
control all the time this is a challenge
that the whole industry faces and
they're working on different solutions
to warn or re-engage the driver at em
vdn self-driving cars running with AI
present a new version of the trolley
problem how does the car make an ethical
decision about who to kill by running
over so in one classic version of the
trolley car problem you're a bystander
and you see a trolley headed towards
five people on the track you can switch
to another track where only one is
killed do you pull that switch automated
vehicles have to consider situations
where there may be loss of life but
they're not really using this sort of
moral calculus part of my work with a
safety adviser for Ford I actually
helped develop a set of rules that
autonomous vehicles could use and this
just simply involves following the duty
of care that the law outlines now if
other people violate their duty of care
to the car by jumping in front of it
when it doesn't have enough time to
avoid a crash you can program the
autonomous vehicle to do the best it can
to do everything under its power to
avoid that crash autonomous vehicles are
out there protecting people who follow
the rules and not making determinations
about who's more worthy to live or die
at the aot asks if my self-driving car
gets into an accident why wouldn't
whomever made the car be at fault I
wasn't driving if a car is driving
itself the manufacturers will in general
be liable for that Mercedes has already
made a very strong statement with their
level three Drive pilot that if it has a
crash the company is responsible and not
the human driver so we're shifting
really into an entirely different world
in fact in San Francisco they've already
run into the problem of how does a
police officer give a ticket to an
autonomous vehicle that doesn't make
sense when there's not a driver at mbj
2042 why would I buy a hydrogen car when
I could charge my electric vehicle at
home think for a moment about over- the
road heavy trucks in order to recharge
them they would actually need vast
amounts of electrical charging
capability if they wanted to do that in
a reasonable period of time they'd also
have to carry massive amounts of
batteries hydrogen may actually make
sense for buses over the road heavy
trucks probably not going to replace
your electric vehicle and your charger
at home at digital blade CA wonders if
you had to solve real world driving
would you go down the path of
programming the rules of the road and
expect the car to obay or let a neural
network learn to drive like an
experienced Uber driver you really want
a combination of these techniques so
Tesla they use neural networks to learn
from their camera system and what the
cars are likely to do around them in
contrast Mercedes level three system
tends to rely on rules Engineers can
program specific behaviors into the car
to ensure that it follows the traffic
laws or follows a vehicle at an
appropriate distance at Chum asks I'm
really concerned about security when
autonomous cars take over what if
they're hacked hacking is a real concern
with automated Vehicles particularly
those systems that can receive over the
air software updates there's also a
threat as we move towards AI systems
that hackers could get involved with the
data stream AI in an autonomous vehicle
is trained by feeding it lot of data
which could be for instance a series of
camera images if you could hack that set
of images you could make it so that the
vehicle failed to recognize certain
objects in the environment and that
could create some serious safety risk at
raver Bren asks why do cars have four
wheels because we found out that is a
really great combination to design
vehicles that are stable comfortable and
high performing motorcycles have two
wheels and it's up to the rider to
balance with a car the suspension
handles all of the balance as my car
goes around a corner my tire forces
increase on the outside and decrease on
the inside to keep the car upright if
you have a three-wheel car you actually
have only two of those Wheels helping to
keep the car upright and what this means
is that the weight can shift very
dramatically from one wheel to the other
these cars have a much greater tendency
to roll over at Mountain de MLG asks why
aren't we all driving electric cars by
now it's not a technology that makes
sense for every body range remains a
limitation if you want to take a long
road trip but it is going to take you
some time to stop and recharge your car
more time than it would take you to fill
up a gasoline tank so for many people an
electric vehicle is cheaper because they
can lug it in at their home and use
their own electricity but if you have to
charge your vehicle all the time at a
commercial charging facility you're
likely not going to save that much money
at Dubai future asks will autonomous
vehicles reduce the number of accidents
so autonomous vehicles will certainly
eliminate some forms of human error
autonomous vehicles don't text while
driving they don't drive impaired
they're never distracted because they
can see
360° around the vehicle autonomous
vehicles won't eliminate all errors but
they will shift from the human driving
errors to the programming errors over
time that should be a shift towards
safer cars so those are all the
questions for today thanks for watching
Automotive
support